Pues sí los candidatos ya han ejercido
su voto en las respectivas ciudades
ante una gran expectación es son unas
elecciones muy esperadas desde hace años
ambos candidatos como decíamos ya han
votado el opositor que mal Philips lo ha
hecho ante una grandísima expectación
como no podía ser de otra forma ha
hablado con los medios y ha dicho que la
primavera está por llegar aludiendo al
posible cambio que pueda haber después
de estas elecciones en la presidencia
donde él Debería
Debería ser el ganador en este caso
resista hiperdogán también ha tenido
palabras para la prensa Donde ha
destacado que lo más importante es que
la gente vote libremente y que no haya
problemas al realizar las votaciones
Albert Y cuéntenos por qué se espera una
más alta participación de lo habitual en
Turquía
Sí en las primeras horas de la mañana ya
hemos podido observar que en los
Colegios había
una había muchísima gente que ya estaba
ejerciendo su derecho a voto nos que
comentaban en las mesas electorales que
solamente en tres horas ya había votado
más de un tercio de la gente aquí la
mayoría de la gente ha estado votando en
las primeras horas de la mañana y
efectivamente es una es una votación
masiva de todos los turcos y turcas hoy
aquí en Turquía debido a la inflación
que hay en estos momentos y a la crisis
económica mucha gente está ejerciendo un
voto de protesta contra el líder del
país por lo tanto se espera que la
participación sea efectivamente una de
las más altas de la historia y que dicen
los últimos sondeos frente al repunte
del líder opositor
la mayoría de los sondeos dicen que qué
mal que el líder opositor se impondría
en estas elecciones había sondeos que
incluso le daban una ventaja de 5 puntos
respecto a hiperdogán ahora mismo en
mínimos de popularidad históricos llega
a estas elecciones con una popularidad
totalmente
demacrada debido como hemos dicho a la
inflación a la crisis económica incluso
hay encuestas que apuntan que que mal
que se podría llegar a imponer en esta
primera ronda hoy